look at this conceptually so here I am
trying to enter the understand and not
go online not a triptych okay you're
trying to change this situation but
trying to enter for some reason I turn
too much
he turned too much I didn't get in
enough but I'm out here so I'm going to
find his Center not through here why not
that's not on my Center but you see this
is all my Center so this is what this is
where I take it ok I'm pretty his body
in this angle you see when I use the
Kota - it's because of what he and I are
able to accomplish here if he was
straight up and regains his balance
that's not good that's the dumbest thing
you could do so I have to make sure he
doesn't so he is going to lift but I'm
not going to let him get straight up
easy so aggressive aggression boom he's
here
[Music]
I'm also not going to prioritize a
particular grid I'm just about
connection do I have this sensor when
you gets up you think
I'm going to do the same thing with my
projection so here here when I do this
is still up things I'm not bothered it's
still a projection Oh as I come around
this is still going to be this is my
contact point don't you have it swinging
arms swinging arm find our Center
through whatever you're touching we have
to correct our understanding of what's
going on we got to here and I told you
I'm taking attention and I'm doing it in
the way that I phone right from the
inside and he resists this position so
he comes up but when he comes up he is
checking me he's checking me goodness
and so it's he if we're here and he
comes up and he's not stretching me what
you are doing then I don't throw him
what do I do
I'd beat the crap out of them okay so I
go here he goes dad look you're going to
be a terrible who care you read in Texas
and I'm this year okay that this is the
end of my coat of ash and sense okay I'm
just going to do whatever I need to do
to finish this so you can
it's creating the logic for my follower
he got up but he didn't give me my arm
and because I'm trying to throw his
Center I feel that I'm checked out by
him not because I'm trying to do an arm
twist you understand its energy energy
relationship that I master so his center
has to be in the arm that's why this is
this
if he's here and he gets up checking me
and I go to punch him he all brah
he's going to happen because he was
checking me just like sword the sword
contacting you so I want you to slow it
down because what happen is whether you
kill uses their balance their cowardice
takes over they go egocentric they lose
the check they lose their connection and
now you're doing a move you should not
be doing that
so we'll slow it down okay it's going to
work on keeping that check they get up
and I move around the check do you
understand this difference one I have
them internal boom he gets up with the
check on my arm and I take that into the
test take up this the technique is not
my contriving okay so if I go here and
he you see how he took it off can I move
my hands yeah okay so maybe I start with
one and kick him into the throat versus
he'll keep keep checking me the whole
way you see and I have to pass it the
whole way so if I let go in here can you
stick to me easy that was over your hand
if you're going to stick to me the exact
inspection weeks in his arms mixed I
would just use a boom so why then did I
only why did I not throw him on the 45
cuz he's checked to me the whole life
he's already opened it he's checked me
the hallways many maintaining content
those higher time I'm looking for the
attendance oh I'm looking for that you
need to be more responsive okay you're
you you go you're pretty much going oh
that's it okay go nothing to
sophisticate my my practice right I look
yet
that would it doesn't would be
jammed that's right
so I have to go here I'm always going to
fire road by the antenna before anything
up if he keep connection he won't get
hurt
[Music]
go